it doesn't get any better than this this
is the dream slam dunk contest we've all
been dying to see i'm talking zion
williamson
taking on john moran in a head-to-head
dunk only highlights match-up
i'm not here to talk about who the best
player is i'm only here to see
who has the best highlights our
categories today to help us decide our
poster
off the break off the glass which is our
surprisingly great category
off the rim and off the bounce and it's
going down right here
on one on one this episode of one on one
is presented by
state farm when it comes to insurance
you can get the personalized service of
a local agent
for a surprisingly great rate with state
farm let me introduce to you my co-host
you know this guy very well he's an nba
veteran
and a podcast star my guy quentin
richardson
this is super exciting for me man these
are two of the most exciting young
players to my favorite young players and
look
i'm excited to get this road all right
i'm going to introduce somebody who
we are incredibly blessed to be in the
presence of this
is the founder the og of the slam dunk
the godfather of the
poster ladies and gentlemen hall of
famer
nba aba champ nvp the list goes on and
on
julius the doctor
amen appreciate the shout out good good
good to be with you guys
uh you know i'm just kind of sitting on
the sidelines these days but i've been
checking
you know checking the players out i'm
checking zion out checking jaw out
you know they they both have that it
factor
uh they know how to bring it in hard and
heavy
uh for the in your face dunk they know
how to get away on the breakaways
and do something flashy and memorable so
if there ever was a slam dunk contest
and these two were featured
i'd be hard to pick you know who would
be the winner but i know that the winner
would be well
deserving all right the first category
for today's matchup
is poster now the the term posterize was
literally created to describe
you dr j so we're looking at the
incredible bang bang bang
on that let's see what we do y'all ready
john marant over oh my god
all right listen when he hit him with
the baba
the crossover and then he like the part
is impressive is that when he went up
baines hit him with one of those a
little bit and he went he shifted in
there but he went so hot he still just
threw it
as he was falling by when i literally
when i saw this play you know it was it
was
it was poet it was poetry in motion
and you said he got up i want pause
right here though look
look at the face that gorilla face right
there
yeah hey listen listen yeah he was
feeling it but he was
he was she was holding it in that face
man he ttg
you remember when he got drafted he
talked about that he trained to go
that's what that face is right there
that's
i'm ttg this ain't i'm not new to this
i'm true to this i do this
you can do a lot of things at that
particular time
but if you know what you've done
it's something that you came to do you
know that you're capable of doing
and you will you're probably better at
doing it than a whole lot of other
people
or whatever you know you know you don't
have to beat your drunk all right let's
move on to the next clip this is zion
williamson taking on the kings
and something something nasty went down
there we go
uh-huh
put put the put the put the gauntlet
blub on that that is that is
thanos that is the human form of
donald did you just say that he's he's
making it look like a stroll in the park
though
he just said no
yeah i don't have to collect myself like
for real
he did that but it was all in one quick
motion and it was over with before
my man even know what happened to him he
didn't put look put on a poster
put that on the wheaties buzz frame it
whatever you want to do like you are
other guy other guys
this was like a drill in practice you
know a dummy dummy drill as they say
all right it's time to put our bids in
i'm most impressed
by the jammo ranch slam in your grill
over aaron it just looks feels sounds
like insanity to me doc what are you
thinking
i'mma go with uh zion
because uh you know it's it was it was
a minor all model it's not a mismatch
situation
q what's up man who wins hi you put me
in the position to be the tie breaker
man listen while i
listen i respect and i love what zion
did on that play
aaron banks is the bonafide wwe
superstar whenever he want to be but
he's in the nba
he went top shelf over him so
young boy fresh aka chill 5th mvp
john rank gets my vote sorry doc i
totally agree once you said that
actually
don't apologize you know it's it's
personal opinion i mean it is
what it is doc you're just you're nba
royalty i just gotta tread lightly man i
don't wanna
i don't wanna let any smoke with you
at all i just had to check it real quick
all right category 2
is off the break we're going to check
out some fast break slam dunks
let's get right into it all right here
we go oh this is going to be nasty you
can already tell
oh my god oh my god
but how uh ew
look at the young looking are you gonna
yell at the basketball
basketball they do nothing to you young
boy
that's a reach back throw down yeah
because you reach back
and you know you know put the mid on it
and you're literally flying through the
air defense has no
no option other than get the hell out of
the way
and whatever you in the rim i mean
that's that's skywalking right that's
skywalking
look at that that's flying through the
air that's like when you hear
you talking about doc and mj and kobe
and lebron like that's flying through
the air right there
all right let's move on to zion's clip
okay this is
this is back this is back in the day oh
oh my goodness
it's already unfair
like hey listen this is back in the
unfair
high school right yes this is a high
school game
uh this is a high school game in south
carolina where zion decided he just
wanted to go
off and just stop the internet i am zion
williams
anything from him in high school it is
not fair that is
it looked like he was playing against
little sixth and seventh grade
like private school kids that had no
shot
no chance like and he was i don't know
what what league what level like what
as far as like carolina but i don't know
what legal it didn't matter
he was on a completely different planet
if they were going straight from high
school
to the nba he was gone i mean he's you
know he's definitely gonna have a hall
of fame career and uh
he's just gonna be fun to watch so i'm
enjoying it
i'm gonna say this right now looking at
both clips this is a no-brainer i don't
think we need to talk
about anything this is going to zion
this is ridiculous this dunk is
ridiculous no one should be able to ever
do this
i don't care if you got the easiest fast
break of all time this is not easy to do
i'm going with zion doc what do you say
i'm going to take jobs on this one okay
q
it's on you again
y'all keep throwing that in the cabin
but listen listen
everything from this kid from high
school was literally
amazing it was viral it was it was out
of here and i i think
who not used to seeing six seven six
eight whatever he is
two hundred and half many pound you're
not used to seeing juggernaut
go up and defy gravity and do things
that we've seen some of the greats do at
that
size weight and and just the ferocity
and the velocity and everything he
brings to the
i gotta go on this one dion gets the w
he wins the category gets my vote gets
q's vote
doc i'm just checking in again and
making sure we're good
you're good man you're good you you know
you don't know what you don't know
our next category is off the glass in
this category we'll run a dunk from each
player that looks like it's going
terribly wrong but
ends up going surprisingly great let's
check them out
oh oh no oh
and then he and he makes him look so
easy first time i saw this play
uh it was when i was a senior vice
president for orlando magic and tracy
mcgrady
did it did it did it in game so
there's been a number of times
afterwards in which there was the past
to yourself it is
spectacular catching the other team by
surprise
and you know making it making a special
play like that whenever you see this in
a game
everyone doesn't know how to react
because it just doesn't happen
so when you see a guy come out here it's
real he has enough confidence to try to
but i i look at it two ways it's either
like you say you got to have supreme
confidence to pull that move to even
attempt that move
or you got to be extremely reckless i
think you know
that john is just more extremely
confident like t-mac
and like vince before him they had the
extreme confidence in that green light
to do so
i'm anxious to see what clip we have of
zion let's check it out now i i don't
know
i don't know okay oh
god i remember that oh i remember that
that was that was ridiculous i gotta
watch this is one
you just gotta watch a couple times real
quick you
definitely have to watch the replay to
appreciate what actually happened it
happened so fast in real motion that you
don't really see
it hit off the glass then he caught it
because if you look at it in fact it
looks like oh that was a regular no
that's not regular
he's not supposed to be able to do that
at that size
i don't care what nobody said that don't
it looks like a video game bro that look
he's a creative player in nba 2k
he went up there and put on his air
brake stayed up there long enough
to meet like i don't know go up and come
down
but if you got that air brake you put on
the air brake and he stayed up there
long enough for it to come off the glass
and then then throw it down see doc
speaking from a whole different realm
i'm i'm i'm a normal athlete normal nba
player that was
if somebody threw that pass to me they
got a turnover i'm not gonna hang around
and get it
you hey and i'm gonna look at him like
who you thought i was on that like
ain't going to get that but like him
he's one of those guys
it don't matter just put it up there he
gonna make it happen
since this is the surprisingly great
category
i think that zion's play really makes no
sense like this
should not have happened like this is
surprisingly great i'm going with zion
williamson that was surprisingly great
that was insane that makes no sense
i agree doc what do you say we haven't
i just want to start off saying we
haven't agreed once we haven't agreed
yet
we haven't agreed we haven't agreed yet
but we're going to agree this time
i mean uh the reason why
it's just an uh inhuman defeat uh that
he did i mean
he takes a he takes a sure turnover and
fast break for the other team
if anybody else was standing under the
basket or cutting the basket
except for him and and maybe giannis and
maybe giannis
this would have been a turnover love it
what you got
i gotta go with zion because that play
it's a lot of athletes a lot of great
athletes and a lot of supreme athletes
but to catch that thing off the board
when you were expecting to catch it
regular
that takes some some different type of
athleticism and a different type of
being special so i mean for me
i don't think i could ever done that but
i don't think i could ever done either
play but i mean i think that the zion
play was more impressive
when you talk about body size and
everybody's you know
what he brings to the i think that was
the more impressive play so with this
one
i gotta go with zion which means the off
the glass category is going to zion
williamson
another one for zion next category is
off the rim this is my favorite category
because these are not made dunks these
are mist dunks but it's sometimes the
missed ones that
were the best ones what could have been
y'all already know what we're gonna show
that's why oh my oh my
lord have mercy we love you kevin love
but
omg good lord telling my kids your dead
used to defy
gravity call nassau i used to leave some
earth
do you hear me oh
yeah this is one of those misses that it
doesn't even matter
kevin love hilton that's a good guy
right there that's a good guy
[Music]
lie like i know this is a show we gotta
watch the next clip like
do we really need to watch the next clip
for this category
this is ridiculous
[Applause]
that is the exact sentiment look at the
kid did i just see what i just saw like
oh my god
that didn't like bro the only thing i
compare to that
is when i was in person watching aaron
gordon and zach levine do what they did
in toronto
that's how i was looking as a former
player like this is
that is what that is like miss dunks
made dunks it was like oh wait a minute
i'm seeing something i've never
seen before in my life in real life like
right here i'm not looking through a tv
or a lens this is happening
like wow that dunk whether he made it
miss it or something in between was
absolutely phenomenal and disrespectful
and for that jaws getting my boat this
time around
yes doc what do you think you know he
had both his legs
above the guy's shoulder yeah one thing
i mean that's a that's what that's a
phenomenal thing that's that's slam dunk
slam dunk contest q what do you think
are you with us or what
hey man listen we got another clean
sweep right here man no way possible i'm
going against the grain with this one
big young boy fresh job and ran
man listen i remember kevin uh kevin
love's tweet
i remember the world going crazy and
saying what if and i
just that free shot that picture right
there
that's that is crazy that it like you
say
he is a little guy going top champ over
tick 16 plus
like he taking a challenge and he going
up and over somebody like
that right there is that that wins it
for me
josh went in this category hands down i
don't think we have anything else to
talk about
john made history with that miss john's
getting that one
[Laughter]
all right it's time to settle this this
is the last category off the bounce
we're tied up 2-2 with each of these
guys
we're seeing who's got the hops who's
got the bunnies who deserves to win this
highlight battle
i'm ready to watch these highlights
let's get right to it
yup oh oh no
[Applause]
let's not disrespect the circus act the
curly meal act before he even go to the
to
the
launch pad he did a whole isaiah thomas
ridge before he got to the launch pad
and took off
and his four defenders
when he gets below the foul line he's
taking off four guys his guys didn't
even run dude
this guy didn't run they like still at
half court they got
four defenders and then they were one
other guy yeah it's like
two or four and they knew where he was
going and he knew where he was going he
was not gonna be denied
listen when you watch this it screams
out
special like that man just went one on
five and then hit the launch pad that's
what john moran is he get that one two
gather together whoever down there
bless your heart good night you about to
be other guy on the poster
i don't care what nobody looks like
other guy
welcome to the poster look at him and he
come down like he know that why you call
himself a point
guard that boy especially
[Music]
that's i'm not gonna lie that's gonna be
a tough one to beat let's check out zion
williamson's
clip now here we go no
that's bad
[Applause]
um this was his first ever career dunk
that's crazy first ever career dunk
is contested he's with his offhand you
know he's lefty right
right with his right hand so that that
makes it you know a little bit more
uh interesting i'm gonna have to give it
to zion that is impressive
that was nasty that was ridiculous
i'm giving it to zion okay doc what's
your thing
i'm giving it to y'all man i'm getting a
good job he's just saying i'm here to
stay
and uh you know i'm young yeah i know
i'm young but i'm establishing my place
and uh and that nobody's gonna stand in
my way
i'm going with zion you're going with
john q it's on you bro
listen man for the first time today
your lack of playing games and lack of
having
nba or any type of hoop game has shown
his rear
weirdest ugly hair for you christian me
and me and me and john
are in sync on this one john dan stoner
man he danced on him he went one on
five dancing playing the piano
and then he hit the launch pad like you
know you used to jump off the
trampolines and bang that thing he
looked like he hit that
that that area and jumped off a
trampoline launched in the air but then
he came down and said hey
hey calm down i do this all the time
this ain't the first time y'all gonna
see it again be cool
chill fix young boy fresh drive around
get my vote
which means john murray is the first
winner of one on one presented by
state farm q comes in the clutch with
the vote for job
i'm not even mad at it this was the
hardest decision to make
it was it was zionism
and i love everything he doing
everything he gonna do but
the the young boy fresh aka chilled
fifth
mvp the the 6-2 small
guy that he rep for the for the small
guards today
it was good exciting action to watch uh
you know
even seeing the throwing off the glass
you know turning the clock back
a little bit you know every season
somebody you know comes with that play
yeah well it's an absolute honor to be
blessed by a hall of famer the godfather
of the
dunk julius dr j irvin thank you so much
for joining us on one on one
q you're the man i appreciate you and
all those watching thank you this
episode was brought to you by state farm
like a good neighbor state farm is there